c'est dans ce champ sur les hauteurs de
clamecy que le feu s'est déclaré hier
vers 17 heures très rapidement les
flammes se sont répandues favorisé par
la sécheresse et le vent
en à peine trois heures 120 hectares ont
été brûlés pour éteindre les flammes
un important dispositif a été déployé
avec des équipes venues de toute la
nièvre mais aussi de l'yonne nous avions
environ quinze engins d'attac quinze
engins
deux types camion citerne feux de forêt
qui ont été engagés ainsi que environ
soixante sapeurs-pompiers plus tout ce
qui est commandement tout ce qui est
véhicules logistiques soutien sanitaire
à proximité se situe une décharge
sauvage selon les premières
constatations cet incendie pourrait être
lié à un acte imprudent a priori un feu
d'origine intentionnelle
c'est à dire intentions intentionnelle
simplement une personne qui a mis le feu
pour faire brûler des détritus
semble-t-il
le sinistre a été maîtrisé vers 19h30
mais une surveillance a été maintenue
une bonne partie de la nuit
depuis le début de l'année celle
incendie le plus important qu'ils aient
eu lieu dans le département